all right i was on with dan patrick
yesterday and he asked me which of the
two quarterbacks i would pay a long-term
big money contract to first dak prescott
or jared goff you know how i feel about
this i went prescott right away what's
your position on prescott versus god i'm
with you mike i mean if you make me
choose who i'd rather have us by
quarterback i am choosing dak prescott i
mean first of all you know hey uh let's
just get into it i mean let's go you
know player verse player here okay who's
got better size dak prescott you know
who's a better athlete dak prescott
who's got a stronger arm very close
i probably would still go dak prescott
who can make plays happen off schedule
dak prescott so who can you know who can
you design quarterback run game design
plays for dak prescott so again jared
goff is a good football player don't get
me wrong and you can obviously win
football games with him but i think dak
prescott is a more talented football
player uh and i think he's been an
offense with you know less creativity in
the past game too to where yeah the
numbers might not look as
sexy but he's got to do a lot more in
that offense in the past game with just
his pure ability in him making the plays
where jared goff as you and i i think we
both agree is served up a lot of easy
completions because of sean mcvay's
genius
i mean think about it you flip
dak prescott and jared goff he put goff
with jason garrett and prescott with
sean mcvay
yeah that would be up that would be an
intriguing chemistry experiment to see
how that would work out and the thing
for me with goff
and we've talked about this at what
point does a team say no we're not
making you the highest paid player in
nfl history we're not giving you 35
million dollars a year we're just not
doing it i feel like goff is one of the
prime candidates to get that message
when the time comes to sit down and
negotiate a long-term deal that the rams
aren't going to break the bank for jared
goff that they believe if they have to
they could go find somebody younger that
mcveigh handpicks to run his system that
can get it done as well as jared goff
for a hell of a lot less money yeah mike
i mean
[Music]
i hear you i don't know if i totally
believe it right i i i'm with you in the
fact that jared goff would be one of the
prime candidates for me for a guy that
you know doesn't get the big time
contract i do think mcveigh and les
snead are the type of guys to have the
guts to make that type of decision also
so that leads me there but then also i
look at it and go gosh so the la rams
since jared goff is taken over okay
they've gone to the playoffs twice they
went to the super bowl he's a california
kid he went to cal at college i just
feel like ultimately
that the rams will cave in this and give
jared goff the money but i i have some
of the same sentiments you do
but this isn't joe namath right i mean
if you're going to factor in california
factors l.a factors hollywood factors
jared goff doesn't have that in him
right he's kind of a soft-spoken guy
and he's not i'm not saying he's a bad
quarterback and you know this is like
how the raiders fans react when i say
derek carr
probably won't be there next year i'm
saying goff is a guy who he's not he's
not bad you just have to ask yourself
how much of a financial investment do
you want to make and i keep going back
to that play in the second half of the
super bowl when the rams were waking up
and brandon cooks was wide open and goff
didn't anticipate it didn't see it and
when he finally saw it he threw a ball
that wasn't accurate enough to get the
cooks before jason mccourty closed like
a 25-yard gap yeah right in two seconds
so i i i just that that's the
championship moment i was talking about
this on radio you have very few moments
like that where you can establish that
you have the championship gene
and goff had the chance and he failed
chris and to me i don't want to wait for
more of these opportunities to come to
the conclusion that he doesn't have it
you either have it or you don't and you
had your chance to prove it and you
failed and sorry but that's just the way
it is yeah no i i hear you and i mean
add to what you're saying i mean he had
that same exact play earlier in the game
same exact play same exact coverage and
he didn't throw the ball up then so yeah
it's a little concerning when you go
damn here's the same play against the
same coverage and he didn't see it the
second time in a row and then when he
did see it his physical ability and his
arm strength weren't good enough to make
up for the fact that he was way late on
it and like you said jason mccordy 30
yards away had enough time to break on
the ball and break it up but yeah
that'll be the big question there you
know because jared goff the stats the
numbers the wins they're gonna all look
pretty good and that's gonna lead i
think to that california what i'm just
saying that push where he's the
franchise quarterback look at his
quarterback rating look at this
touchdown interception ratio and i want
to go yeah okay that's cool but gosh
there's a lot of quarterbacks that have
played in la the last two years who
could have similar stats because you
know it's not that difficult to throw
the ball four yards to todd gurley and
then he runs 70 or you know throw a guy
open wide open over the middle that sean
mcveigh game plan perfectly for so those
are the things they're gonna have to
figure out
one last point on this too we're not
privy to what conversations happened and
during that 30 minute half time or
while sean mcvay was talking to jared
goff as he was calling that play but as
you pointed out they ran that play
earlier in the game and cooks was wide
open and goth didn't see it now
let's apply basic logic and common sense
here do we think that at some point it
was communicated to goff we're going to
run that again and cooks is the guy to
look for and if that's what was said to
goff and he blew it the second time
that's when you have to start thinking
is sean mcvay is this really the guy
that i want to hitch my wagon to for the
next 10 years yeah valid point yeah at
the very least yeah you're right what
would concern me there was go man he
didn't even process what we said the
first time around was this game too big
was the moment too freaked out
yeah that's right his head's spinning
it's the super bowl they're talking to
him but he's just going oh yeah right so
that's normal and not everyone can rise
to that moment but when you show me you
can't rise to that moment i start maybe
thinking is there somebody else out
there who can yeah i hear you mike it's
a valid question it's gonna be
interesting to see how it all plays out
i'm mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports